[Musique]
joseph peraste bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes le maire sortant du marigot
vous avez raté de peu l'élection au
premier tour le 15 mars dernier la liste
que vous menez ensemble pour un marigot
fort et solidaire a obtenu 49,47 % des
suffrages exprimés soit environ 8 148
voix
vous analysez pas manger et mairesses
vous analyser comment ce premier tour
est bien en place en cette élection dans
son contexte puisque n'êtes pas sans
savoir que deux jours avant le problème
du colonat virus s'est posée donc nous
l'avons vu nous l'avons constaté le jour
de l'élection beaucoup de gens sont
venus avec leurs masques avec le aux
gants avec leur big donc je préfère
penser que certains n'ont pas pu aussi
se déplacer d'ailleurs l'impact réel de
la coordination sur l'élection si
surtout que c'était fraîchement dit
fraîchement annoncé par les services de
l'état qui disait de prendre beaucoup de
dispositions avant de s'y rendre
donc les gens préféré ne pas venir mais
je reconnais que beaucoup ont eu le
courage puisqu'il faut savoir pour
marigot ils ont voté exceptionnellement
à 50 plus de 50% par rapport à d'autres
communes qui ont voté à 15 à 20 ou à 30%
et sur 50% des deux suffrages exprimés
bien je suis arrivé à 49,47 % ce qui
pour moi c'est quelque chose quand même
d'extraordinaire et j'en remercie la
population vous restez l'élection à neuf
voix l'élection premier tour 1 9 voix
vous à monter quoi vous n'avez pas été
chercher les gens assez lent je dirais
simplement que la nature a voulu que ce
soit comme ça et puis que je sois ici
aujourd'hui pour donner un peu plus
d'explications à la population
donc je remercie dieu je remercie la
nature d'avoir provoqué les choses
puisque nous sommes restés un petit peu
plus longtemps dans les élections que
d'autres villes autres environ 55% de
toute participation au 1er tour vous
pensez encore mobiliser les jeunes
marie goater comment pour ce second tour
eh bien je pense un et ça va vous
étonner ce que je vais dire je ne sais
pas le seul à mobiliser l'électorat mes
adversaires aussi de par leur
comportement
je pense que ça va mobiliser
terriblement l'électorat parce que les
gens vont se dire mais peyras qui
affronte 6 mai mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font là mais non mais non on y va et
j'ai l'impression que nous passerons les
70% de participation et là je ferai un
score plus qu'honorable
quel sera votre projet phare si vous
vous si vous êtes réélu alors pourquoi
un projet phare que vous allez recours
relance et aux biens pouces des phares
que vous allez continuer alors il y a
plusieurs projets phares puisque jallet
dit au coût de la campagne du premier
temps la ville du marigot un tas mais un
certain nombre déjà deux dossiers tels
que la construction d'une structure
d'accueil pour personnes âgées la
réalisation d'un plateau sportif au
lotissement fond d'or pour la jeunesse
de ce quartier le stade dont qui a fait
beaucoup de bruit
j'ai commencé les travaux mais le projet
jo compte je pense d'ici fin 2020 début
2021 va démarrer puisque le projet déjà
été confiée à cap nord donc je suis en
attente d'aidé avant cette cap nord nous
avons l'école de baignoires à
reconstruire
nous avons aussi d'autres projets qui
ont été déjà présentés à la population
mais je vous ai donné les quelqu'un
priorité sur les finances de la ville
il y avait une tentative de de vous
rappeler à l'ordre par le préfet je
crois qu'il a été
il a été peut-être lui-même rappelé à
l'ordre par l'ue que ce soit moi
pourquoi ce n'était pas justifié
je ne peux pas dire que ce soit justifié
ou pas justifiée quand monsieur le
préfet je pense se lance dans des
investigations des gens ils pensaient
précaution bon je reste persuadé
peut-être qu'il y a eu une erreur
d'aiguillage à un moment donné mais je
vais pas non plus me me mettra je ne
dirais pas à appliquer à ce niveau je
dirais simplement que oui
la commune du marigot peut effectivement
avoir des difficultés financières mais
je ne crois pas que ce soit quelque
chose de nouveau dans ce pays on parle
de 3 10 ans lorsqu'elle 300000 euros
savez c'est très peu un pour certaines
villes en fonction du budget je pense
que ça peut avoisiner cette somme nous
verrons puisque si le préfet l'a fait a
fait cette annonce est un site à retiers
il y a des raisons peut-être que nous
allons trouver des erreurs ou peut-être
encore que il va poursuivre le moment
venu face à cette pandémie qu'est ce que
ça vous a obligé de dufer qu'est-ce que
vous avez dû faire face à cette pandémie
pour pour juste pas par exemple pour le
second tour pour mener à bien votre
campagne
oui alors je omis de vous dire tout à
l'heure que dans ce budget d'au moins
300 mille euros je pense aussi que le
préfet a dû se rendre compte qu'il y
avait peut-être les sargasses qui pesé
beaucoup sur ce budget de fonctionnement
puisque nous en sommes à plus de 150000
euros rien que pour l'année 2019 pour
des dépenses de fonctionnement des
sargasses donc je reviens un peu pour
dire pourquoi peut-être qu'on a dû
retirer 1 puisque mes adversaires
semblent me donne un pouvoir en me
disant que j'ai eu le pouvoir sur le
préfet que j'ai donné des instructions
alors il nous reste très peu de temps
vraiment 15 secondes votre question
c'était dans cette pandémie la caisse
qui vous comment vous organisez pour ce
second tour
dernière que c'est vraiment la dernière
qui est tout à fait alors il faut savoir
que pour cette pandémie
la ville du marigot a été la première et
l'unique à mettre à la disposition de la
population du marigot un dispositif
d'accompagnement communal
au vu de 19 de la martinique ça a été la
ville du marigot
c'est à dire que j'ai pris avec des
contacts avec tous les professionnels de
santé
je les ai rassemblé je les ai au groupe
et nous avons fait des visioconférences
et tout et ces gens se sont mis à la
disposition d'abord de la population
margot tine et ensuite de la population
martiniquaise joseph peraste je vous
remercie